oh my god when kylo Ren that was raising
spoilers spoilers already sorry yeah who
didn't raise parents are okay so I have
a lazy bum yeah you and me we just don't
get along you make me feel like a
Digimon Digimon are the champions I only
[ __ ] you when it's hot outside but I'm
horny
well it's winter should we go no you
stay out in the club like what we be in
the party in the club like right now I'm
or five seconds from wanted I'm for
hungry this joke sucks I'm a farting
carrots oh my god I'm a foxing carrots
uh-oh see that's their real carrots oh
my god again again aah oh Jesus
no that's one more time and I got the
soda I'm glad to see I've got the shits
no uh-oh
this relationship is broken oh we really
should get out here you will stay and
sing you watch me bleed until I can't
breathe shaking falling on the monkeys
oh I just need one more shot half again
is
focus fire a gun oh don't tell your
mother fish in the cupboard watch me
watch me watch me now do my stanky leg
oh I'll do my stanky leg groans ooh my
saggy leg [ __ ]
stanky leg love me like a dude love love
love me like you do to-to-touch me like
and dude touch touch me that I could do
doc divorce say you'll remember me
standing in a nice dress staring at the
sunset babe please welcome to the 1989
World Tour stage my very best friends
Ashley Perez with the birth of ALM yell
mishchenko cuz baby now we got
don't at me AG sorry alright okay Oh God
I'm sorry
ask carrots all over you Oh another one